ברוכים הבאים חזרה להבנת מידע קוונטי וחישוב השם שלי הוא John Watrous ואני המנהל הטכני לחינוך ב-IBM
Quantum זה שיעור מספר 15 בסדרה והוא השיעור השלישי של היחידה הרביעית שעוסקת בתיקון שגיאות
קוונטי עד כה ראינו כמה דוגמאות של קודים לתיקון שגיאות קוונטיות כולל קוד Shore של תשעה qubit
קוד Steane של 7 qubit וקוד של 5 qubit ודיברנו גם על הפורמליזם של מייצבים שמספק
לנו בסיס מתמטי שממנו אפשר לתאר ולנתח את אלה וקודים רבים אחרים לתיקון שגיאות קוונטיות
הקודים שהזכרתי זה עתה הם בלי ספק מעניינים והם מייצגים מקום טבעי להתחיל
חקירה של תיקון שגיאות קוונטי הבעיה היא שהם יכולים לסבול רק שיעור שגיאות מאוד נמוך
לתקן שגיאה ב-qubit אחד מתוך חמישה שבעה או תשעה זה לא רע אבל ככל הנראה לפחות ככל שאנחנו חושדים
נצטרך להיות מסוגלים לסבול הרבה יותר שגיאות מזה כדי להפוך מחשוב קוונטי בקנה מידה גדול
למציאות בשיעור הזה ניקח מבט ראשון על כמה בניות מתוחכמות יותר של קודים לתיקון שגיאות קוונטיות כולל קודים שיכולים
לסבול שיעור שגיאות הרבה יותר גבוה מאלה שראינו עד כה ונחשבים למועמדים מבטיחים לתיקון שגיאות קוונטי מעשי
בהתקנים פיזיים ממשיים הנה סקירה קצרה של השיעור נתחיל עם סוג של
קודים לתיקון שגיאות קוונטיות שנקראים קודי CSS על שם החוקרים שגילו אותם ראשונים Robert Calderbank, Peter
Shor ו-Andrew Steane בניית קוד CSS מאפשרת לקחת זוגות מסוימים של קודים קלאסיים
לתיקון שגיאות ולשלב אותם לקוד קוונטי לתיקון שגיאות כחלק מהדיון הזה
נעיף מבט די מהיר על קודים ליניאריים קלאסיים ונדבר גם על כמה מהתכונות הבסיסיות של קודי CSS
החלק השני של השיעור הוא על קוד שנקרא קוד הטורוס שהוא דוגמה בסיסית ובאמת
יפה של קוד קוונטי לתיקון שגיאות שיכול לסבול שיעור שגיאות יחסית גבוה למעשה
קוד הטורוס הוא לא דוגמה בודדת של קוד קוונטי לתיקון שגיאות אלא הוא משפחה אינסופית של קודים אחד עבור
כל מספר שלם חיובי החל משניים ובחלק האחרון של השיעור נדון בקצרה בכמה משפחות
אחרות של קודים קוונטיים כולל קודי שטח שקשורים קשר הדוק לקוד הטורוס וגם
קודי צבע אנשים חוקרים קודים קלאסיים לתיקון שגיאות מאז שנות ה-40 של המאה ה-20
וזה נושא מרתק ועשיר קודים ליניאריים הם אולי הסוג הפשוט ביותר של קוד קלאסי לתיקון
שגיאות ואסביר בדיוק מה המילה ליניארי אומרת בהקשר הזה עוד רגע אבל דרך אחת פשוטה
לבטא מה הם זה שהם קודי מייצבים שבמקרה הם קלאסיים ונראה בקרוב ש
קודי CSS הם בעצם זוגות של קודים ליניאריים קלאסיים שמשולבים יחד ליצירת קוד קוונטי לתיקון
שגיאות אז לצורך הדיון הזה נצטרך להבין כמה דברים בסיסיים על
קודים ליניאריים קלאסיים קודם כל ניקח את סיגמא כאלפבית הבינארי לכל הדיון
הזה ועכשיו כשאנחנו מתייחסים לקוד ליניארי קלאסי אנחנו מתכוונים לקבוצה C של מחרוזות בינאריות באורך n עבור
מספר שלם חיובי n שמקיימת תכונה בסיסית אחת בלבד והיא שאם u ו-v הן מחרוזות בינאריות ב-C אז המחרוזת
u XOR v גם היא ב-C כאן אגב u XOR v זה ה-exclusive or הביטי של u ו-v בדיוק
כמו שראינו כמה פעמים בשיעורים חמש ושש בחלק של האלגוריתמים הקוונטיים בסדרה וזה מה שאומר שקוד
קלאסי הוא ליניארי במהות אנחנו חושבים על מחרוזות בינאריות באורך n כוקטורים n-ממדיים
שהרכיבים שלהם הם כולם אפס או אחד אבל במקום חיבור וקטורי רגיל מעל המספרים הממשיים או המרוכבים
אנחנו משתמשים בחיבור מודולו 2 שזה פשוט ה-XOR אז אם יש לנו
שתי מילות קוד u ו-v כלומר u ו-v הן מחרוזות בינאריות ב-C אז u ועוד v מודולו 2 או במילים אחרות u XOR
v חייבת להיות גם היא מילת קוד ב-C ואגב המשמעות הזו חייבת להיות נכונה גם אם u שווה ל-v שום דבר לא שולל
את האפשרות הזו וזה מרמז שכל קוד ליניארי קלאסי חייב להכיל את מחרוזת כל האפסים כי
ה-XOR הביטי של כל מחרוזת עם עצמה הוא מחרוזת כל האפסים לדוגמה קוד
החזרה של שלושה ביטים הוא קוד ליניארי קלאסי ספציפית יש שתי בחירות אפשריות ל-u ושתי בחירות אפשריות
ל-v וזה עניין טריוויאלי למדי לעבור על הזוגות האפשריים ולראות שתמיד מקבלים מילת קוד כשלוקחים את ה-XOR הביטי
הנה דוגמה נוספת שנקראת קוד Hamming [7,4,3] זה אחד מהקודים הקלאסיים הראשונים לתיקון שגיאות
שהתגלו אי פעם והוא מורכב מ-16 מחרוזות בינאריות באורך שבע יש לוגיקה מאוד פשוטה
מאחורי בחירת המחרוזות האלה אבל לא אסביר את זה בסרטון הזה וכדאי גם לציין שלפעמים רואים את המחרוזות האלה הפוכות אבל
לעת עתה הנקודה העיקרית היא שאם ניקח כל שתיים מהמחרוזות האלה ונעשה להן XOR נקבל מחרוזת אחרת בקוד
אז זה קוד ליניארי והסימון [7,4,3] בסוגריים מרובעים בודדים אומר משהו אנלוגי לסוגריים מרובעים
כפולים שהזכרתי בשיעור הקודם עבור קודי מייצבים אבל כאן זה עבור קודים ליניאריים קלאסיים
ספציפית למילות קוד יש שבעה ביטים יש 16 מילות קוד אז אפשר לקודד ארבעה ביטים באמצעות הקוד
ובמקרה זה קוד עם מרחק שלוש כלומר צריך להפוך לפחות שלושה ביטים של כל מילת קוד כדי לקבל
מילת קוד אחרת וזה מרמז שהוא יכול לתקן עד שגיאת היפוך ביט אחת אלה דוגמאות פשוטות של
קודים אבל אפילו הדוגמה של קוד Hamming [7,4,3] נראית קצת מסתורית כשפשוט מפרטים את כל מילות הקוד אז צריך דרכים טובות יותר
לתאר קודים ליניאריים קלאסיים ויש שתי דרכים טבעיות לעשות את זה דרך אחת היא לתאר קודים ליניאריים
קלאסיים על ידי נתינת סט מינימלי של מילות קוד שמייצרות את הקוד כלומר שעל ידי לקיחת כל תתי-הקבוצות
האפשריות של מילות הקוד האלה ועשיית XOR ביניהן מקבלים את הקוד כולו וזה מבוטא במונחים מתמטיים
כאן על המסך דרך נוספת לחשוב על זה היא שאנחנו רואים את הקוד כתת-מרחב של מרחב וקטורי והסט
הזה של מחוללים הוא בסיס לתת-המרחב הזה בזכרון שזה מרחב וקטורי שבו אריתמטיקה נעשית מודולו 2 אם יש לנו m מחוללים
נקבל קוד עם שניים בחזקת m איברים כל מחולל מכפיל את מספר האיברים בקוד
וזה עקבי עם העובדה שקודים ליניאריים קלאסיים מעל האלפבית הבינארי תמיד כוללים מספר מחרוזות שהוא חזקה של
שניים הדרך הטבעית השנייה לתאר קוד ליניארי קלאסי היא על ידי בדיקות זוגיות ספציפית זוהי רשימה מינימלית
של מחרוזות בינאריות באותו אורך כמו המחרוזות בקוד כך שהמחרוזות בקוד הן בדיוק אלה שהמכפלה הפנימית הבינארית
שלהן עם כל אחת ממחרוזות בדיקת הזוגיות היא אפס כאשר המכפלה הפנימית הבינארית היא פשוט המכפלה הפנימית הרגילה
מודולו 2 ושוב זה משהו שפגשנו בשיעור חמש בהקשר של אלגוריתמי
שאילתות והסיבה שהן נקראות מחרוזות בדיקת זוגיות היא שמחרוזת נתונה u יש לה מכפלה בינארית שווה
לאפס עם v אם ורק אם הביטים של u שמתאימים לאחדות ב-v הם בעלי זוגיות
זוגית כשאנחנו מתארים קוד ליניארי קלאסי בדרך הזו על ידי רשימה מינימלית של מחרוזות בדיקת זוגיות כל מחרוזת
בדיקת זוגיות מחלקת את מספר המחרוזות בקוד בשניים אז עבור קוד בודד שמתואר בשתי הדרכים האלה תמיד יתקיים m + r שווה
ל-n דבר חשוב אחד לשים לב אליו כאן הוא שהמכפלה הפנימית הבינארית היא לא מכפלה פנימית במובן הפורמלי ובפרט
כששתי מחרוזות יש להן מכפלה פנימית בינארית שווה לאפס זה לא אומר שהן אורתוגונליות בדרך הרגילה שאנחנו חושבים על
אורתוגונליות לדוגמה המכפלה הפנימית הבינארית של המחרוזת אחד אחד עם עצמה היא אפס אז ייתכן ש
אחת ממחרוזות בדיקת הזוגיות נמצאת בעצמה בקוד אז זה פשוט משהו שכדאי לזכור
לדוגמה כפי שכבר יודעים קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים הוא קוד ליניארי אז אפשר לתאר אותו בשתי הדרכים
ספציפית יש רק בחירה אחת של מחולל שעובדת וזה 111 ולחלופין אפשר לתאר
את הקוד עם שתי מחרוזות בדיקת הזוגיות האלה שאמורות להיראות מוכרות מהדיונים הקודמים שלנו על הקוד
הזה ועבור קוד Hamming [7,4,3] אפשר להשתמש במחוללים האלה ובבדיקות הזוגיות
האלה וכאן אגב כל מחרוזות בדיקת הזוגיות מסתבר שהן בעצמן בקוד
הערה אחרונה על קודים ליניאריים קלאסיים רק כדי לחבר אותם לפורמליזם של מייצבים מחרוזות בדיקת הזוגיות
האלה שקולות למחוללי מייצבים שבהם יש רק מטריצות פאולי Z ויחידה לדוגמה מחרוזות בדיקת הזוגיות
110 ו-011 עבור קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים מתאימות בדיוק למחוללי המייצבים ZZ יחידה
ויחידה ZZ וזה עקבי עם הדיון שלנו על נצפים מהסוג הזה מהשיעור
הקודם עכשיו נדון בקודי CSS שהם קודי מייצבים שאפשר לקבל על ידי שילוב יחד של זוגות מסוימים
של קודים ליניאריים קלאסיים עם אותו מספר ביטים בקידודים שלהם זה לא עובד עבור כל שני
קודים ליניאריים קלאסיים לשני הקודים צריך להיות קשר מסוים כפי שנראה בקרוב אבל בכל זאת הבנייה
הזו פותחת הרבה אפשרויות לקודים קוונטיים לתיקון שגיאות המבוססות בחלקן על דברים שלמדנו מיותר מ-75 שנה של
תורת קידוד קלאסית כבר הזכרתי שבפורמליזם של מייצבים מחוללי
מייצבים שמכילים רק מטריצות פאולי Z ויחידה שקולים לבדיקות זוגיות לדוגמה בקוד החזרה של שלושה ביטים
אפשר להשתמש במחרוזות בדיקת הזוגיות 110 ו-011 שמאלצות ששני הביטים השמאליים
שווים ושני הביטים הימניים שווים עבור כל מחרוזת בקוד ושתי מחרוזות בדיקת הזוגיות האלה מתאימות בדיוק למחוללי המייצבים
ZZ יחידה ויחידה ZZ עבור קוד Hamming [7,4,3] אפשר להשתמש
במחרוזות בדיקת הזוגיות האלה והן מתאימות למחוללי המייצבים האלה שבהם פשוט מחליפים כל אחד ב-Z וכל אפס ביחידה
אולי תזהו את מחוללי המייצבים האלה אגב כי אלה שלושה מתוך ששת מחוללי המייצבים של קוד Steane של 7 qubit זה בוודאי
לא צירוף מקרים ונראה בדיוק מה קורה כאן בקרוב ניתן את השם מחוללי מייצבים מסוג Z
למחוללי מייצבים כאלה כלומר שיש להם רק פאולי Z ויחידה כגורמי טנזור
אז X ו-Y אף פעם לא מופיעים במחולל מייצב מסוג Z אפשר גם להתבונן
במחוללי מייצבים שבהם מופיעות רק מטריצות פאולי X ויחידה ואפשר לחשוב על מחוללי מייצבים כאלה כאנלוגיים לחלוטין
למחוללי מייצבים מסוג Z רק שהם בעצם מתארים בדיקות זוגיות בבסיס פלוס מינוס ולא בבסיס
הסטנדרטי לדוגמה אם נחזור לקוד Hamming [7,4,3] אפשר לחשוב על
שלושת מחוללי המייצבים הנותרים מקוד Steane של 7 qubit שבמקרה עוקבים בדיוק אחרי אותו דפוס כמו מחוללי מייצבים מסוג Z עבור הקוד
הזה אבל הפעם מחליפים X באחד במקום Z ומה שמקבלים רק משלושת מחוללי המייצבים האלה
הוא קוד שכולל את 16 המצבים שמוצגים כאן שמקבלים על ידי הפעלת gate של Hadamard על מצבי בסיס
סטנדרטי שמתאימים למחרוזות בקוד Hamming [7,4,3] וכמובן מרחב הקוד שלנו כולל גם
צירופים ליניאריים של המצבים האלה באופן טבעי מחוללי מייצבים מהצורה הזו נקראים מחוללי מייצבים מסוג X
אז אין Y או Z הפעם ועכשיו אפשר להגדיר קודי CSS במונחים
פשוטים קודי CSS הם קודי מייצבים שאפשר לבטא רק באמצעות מחוללי מייצבים
מסוג Z ומחוללי מייצבים מסוג X אז אין Y ואין X ו-Z שמופיעים באותו מחולל
מייצב ורק כדי לוודא שזה ברור צריך לזכור שיש חופש באיך שבוחרים את מחוללי המייצבים עבור קודי
מייצבים ומה שההגדרה הזו אומרת היא שקוד CSS הוא כזה שבו אפשר לבחור רק מחוללי מייצבים מסוג Z ו-X
אבל באופן כללי אפשר לבחור מחוללי מייצבים אחרים שאולי לא יהיו מחוללי מייצבים מסוג Z או X אם רוצים
הנה בערך הדוגמה הלא-טריוויאלית הכי פשוטה של קוד CSS שיכול להיות בו גם מחולל מייצב
מסוג Z וגם מחולל מייצב מסוג X ולאמת את זה לא דורש יותר ממבט בהתחשב בכך שכבר יודעים
מהשיעור הקודם שזהו קוד מייצב תקף מרחב הקוד הוא חד-ממדי זהו המרחב הנפרש על ידי
פי פלוס בל ואפשר להבחין שני מחוללי המייצבים שלנו פועלים באופן טריוויאלי על הוקטור הזה על ידי התבוננות
בשני הביטויים של ebit שמוצגים על המסך יחד עם הפרשנות של מחוללי המייצבים כבדיקות זוגיות בבסיסים 01
ופלוס מינוס קוד Steane של 7 qubit הוא דוגמה נוספת לקוד CSS כי עבור הבחירה
הזו של מחוללים יש לנו רק מחוללי מייצבים מסוג Z ו-X ושוב כבר יודעים שזהו קוד
מייצב תקף וקוד Shor של 9 qubit הוא דוגמה נוספת הפעם יש לנו שישה מחוללי מייצבים
מסוג Z ורק שני מחוללי מייצבים מסוג X וזה בסדר לא צריך להיות איזון או
סימטריה בין שני הסוגים אבל חיוני שבאמת יהיה לנו קוד מייצב תקף וזה אומר
שכל אחד ממחוללי המייצבים מסוג Z חייב להתחלף עם כל אחד ממחוללי המייצבים מסוג X אז אי אפשר
פשוט לבחור את שני סוגי המחוללים באופן בלתי תלוי ואגיד עוד קצת על זה בהמשך השיעור עכשיו נדון בזיהוי
ותיקון שגיאות עבור קודי CSS ומה שנמצא הוא שהתכונה שצפינו בקוד Shor של 9 qubit
שאפשר לזהות ולתקן שגיאות X ושגיאות Z באופן בלתי תלוי מתקיימת באופן כללי עבור קודי CSS
כדי להסביר את זה יותר בואו ניקח קוד CSS כמו קוד Steane של 7 qubit אבל זה יכול להיות קוד CSS אחר אם
אתם מעדיפים הרעיון הבסיסי הוא שמחוללי המייצבים מסוג Z מזהים שגיאות X
אבל הם עיוורים לחלוטין לשגיאות Z כי מחוללי מייצבים מסוג Z תמיד מתחלפים עם שגיאות Z
בנוסף מחוללי המייצבים מסוג Z גם מתחלפים עם כל gate מסוג Z שנבחר להפעיל כ
תיקונים לשגיאות Z באופן דומה מחוללי המייצבים מסוג X מזהים שגיאות Z אבל הם עיוורים
לחלוטין לשגיאות X ולתיקונים אז בעצם אפשר לחשוב על מחוללי המייצבים מסוג Z כמייצגים
קוד ליניארי קלאסי שמגן מפני היפוכי ביטים או במילים אחרות שגיאות X בעוד שמחוללי המייצבים מסוג X
מייצגים קוד ליניארי קלאסי בבסיס פלוס מינוס שבאופן בלתי תלוי לחלוטין מגן מפני היפוכים
בין מצבי פלוס ומינוס או במילים אחרות שגיאות היפוך פאזה או שגיאות Z אז עכשיו זה די ברור מה קורה
עם קוד Steane זה פשוט קוד Hamming [7,4,3] עבור שגיאות היפוך ביט וקוד Hamming [7,4,3] עבור שגיאות היפוך
פאזה שוב העובדה שמחוללי המייצבים מסוג Z ומחוללי המייצבים מסוג X מתחלפים היא הכרחית
זה לא היה קוד מייצב תקף אם הם לא היו מתחלפים ואפשר לומר שזה מזל שקוד Hamming [7,4,3]
מסתדר ככה אבל יש הרבה בחירות אחרות שאפשר לעשות עבור זוגות של קודים ליניאריים קלאסיים שיתנו לנו קוד מייצב תקף
כשמשלבים אותם בדרך הזו עכשיו נחזור לקודי CSS באופן כללי נניח שמחוללי המייצבים
מסוג Z מאפשרים תיקון של עד נגיד j שגיאות X ומחוללי המייצבים מסוג X מאפשרים תיקון של
עד k שגיאות Z אז במקרה של קוד Steane j ו-k שניהם אחד כי
קוד Hamming [7,4,3] יכול לתקן היפוך ביט אחד אבל באופן כללי המספרים j ו-k יכולים להיות שונים
אז נובע מדיסקרטיזציה של שגיאות שקוד ה-CSS יכול לתקן כל שגיאה על מספר qubit עד
המינימום של j ו-k זה בגלל שכאשר מודדים את התסמונת שגיאה שרירותית על מספר
qubit מתמוטטת הסתברותית לשילוב כלשהו של שגיאות X שגיאות Z או שתיהן ואז
את שגיאות ה-X ושגיאות ה-Z אפשר לזהות ולתקן באופן בלתי תלוי אז כל עוד יש לנו שני
קודים ליניאריים קלאסיים שמסתדרים ביניהם במובן שהם נותנים לנו מחוללי מייצבים מסוג X ו-Z שמתחלפים
קוד ה-CSS שמקבלים משילוב שלהם בעצם יורש את תכונות תיקון השגיאות של שני הקודים במובן שהרגע
תיארתי שימו לב שיש מחיר שצריך לשלם והוא שלא ניתן לקודד כל כך הרבה qubit כמו ביטים
עם שני הקודים הקלאסיים כי המספר הכולל של מחוללי מייצבים עבור קוד ה-CSS הוא הסכום של
מספר בדיקות הזוגיות של שני הקודים הקלאסיים וכל מחולל מייצב חוצה את ממד מרחב הקוד
בחצי לדוגמה קוד Hamming [7,4,3] מאפשר קידוד של ארבעה ביטים קלאסיים כי יש לנו רק
שלוש בדיקות זוגיות עבור הקוד הזה בעוד שקוד Steane של 7 qubit מקודד רק qubit אחד כי יש לו שישה
מחוללי מייצבים הדבר האחרון שאסביר על קודי CSS באופן כללי בשיעור הזה נוגע למרחבי הקוד של קודי CSS
ואיך הם נראים וזה גם ייתן לנו הזדמנות לבחון קצת יותר לעומק את היחס שצריך להתקיים בין
שני קודים ליניאריים קלאסיים כדי שיהיו תואמים במובן שאפשר לשלב אותם יחד ליצירת קוד
CSS ניקח קוד CSS כללי על n qubit ויהיו Z1 עד Zs מחרוזות בדיקת הזוגיות
של n ביטים שמתאימות למחוללי המייצבים מסוג Z זה אומר שהקוד הליניארי
הקלאסי שמתואר על ידי מחוללי המייצבים מסוג Z שנקרא לו CZ רק כדי לעזור לנו לזכור ש
זה הקוד שמתאים למחוללי המייצבים מסוג Z מקבל את הצורה שמוצגת כאן על המסך במילים הקוד מכיל כל
מחרוזת u שהמכפלה הפנימית הבינארית שלה עם כל אחת ממחרוזות בדיקת הזוגיות היא אפס ובכן אם רצינו יכולנו גם
לשקול קוד אחר שנגזר מאותן מחרוזות שנקרא לו DZ והרעיון כאן הוא שאנחנו חושבים על
המחרוזות Z1 עד Zs לא כמחרוזות בדיקת זוגיות אלא כמחוללים
בנקודה הזו לא ברור למה נרצה לחשוב על הקוד הזה אבל אפשר וזה יתברר כרלוונטי לדיון
הזה הקוד הזה נקרא הקוד הדואלי של CZ ומסומן בדרך כלל CZ עם סמל ניצב
כחזקה עילית אבל אנחנו נקרא לו DZ וזה מספיק קל לזכור כי D זה קיצור של
דואלי אפשר גם לעשות משהו דומה עם מחוללי המייצבים מסוג X אז הפעם CX הוא הקוד הליניארי הקלאסי
שמחרוזות בדיקת הזוגיות שלו מתאימות למחוללי המייצבים מסוג X ו-DX הוא הקוד הדואלי של קוד זה כהערת אגב
עכשיו אפשר לתאר את התנאים שחייבים להתקיים כדי ש-CZ ו-CX יהיו תואמים במובן שאפשר
לזווג אותם יחד כקוד CSS במונחים של הקודים עצמם ספציפית חייב להתקיים ש
DZ מוכל ב-CX או באופן שקול ש-DX מוכל ב-CZ ועכשיו אפשר
לתאר את מרחב הקוד של קוד ה-CSS שנגזר משני הקודים האלה ודרך אחת לתאר אותו היא שזה
המרחב הנפרש על ידי כל הוקטורים שמקבלים את הצורה שמוצגת על המסך במילים הם נראים כמו סופרפוזיציה
אחידה על המחרוזות בקוד הדואלי DX של הקוד שמתאים למחוללי המייצבים מסוג X מוסטות
על ידי או XOR עם מחרוזות בקוד CZ שמתאים למחוללי המייצבים מסוג Z ונראה איך זה נראה
במקרה הספציפי של קוד Steane עוד רגע זה הגיוני כי מצבים במרחב הקוד חייבים להיות
וקטורים עצמיים עם ערך עצמי פלוס אחד של כל מחוללי המייצבים ובפרט הכפלה בכל אחד ממחוללי המייצבים
מסוג X שקולה ל-XOR עם מחרוזת ה-X המתאימה אז זו הסיבה שסופרפוזיציות אחידות
על DX מוסטות על ידי מחרוזות שונות מופיעות ככה בחירות שונות להסטה
המיוצגות על ידי המחרוזת y בביטוי הזה יכולות לתת לנו את אותו וקטור אגב אז המצבים האלה לא כולם שונים אבל ביחד הם פורשים את
כל מרחב הקוד יש כאן סימטריה בין מחוללי המייצבים מסוג X ו-Z
והקודים שהם מתאימים להם ולכן אפשר להשתמש בסימטריה הזו כדי לתאר וקטורים במרחב הקוד באופן אנלוגי תוך החלפת X ו-Z אבל
צריך גם להחליף את הבסיס הסטנדרטי בבסיס פלוס מינוס וזו הסיבה שפעולות Hadamard מופיעות בביטוי
הזה עכשיו לדוגמה שהובטחה שהיא קוד Steane מגיעים לשני הקידודים האפשריים האלה
כקידודים של מצבי הבסיס הסטנדרטי אפס ואחד ספציפית אפשר לקודד את מצב האפס כסופרפוזיציה
אחידה על שמונה המחרוזות בקוד הדואלי של קוד Hamming [7,4,3] שמסתבר שהוא חצי מהמחרוזות בקוד Hamming [7,4,3] ואפשר
לקודד את מצב האחד באופן דומה רק שכל המחרוזות עוברות XOR עם מחרוזת כל האחדות במקרה הזה
כי המחרוזת הזו נמצאת בקוד Hamming [7,4,3] אבל לא בקוד הדואלי שלו הערה אחרונה כאן היא שלעיתים קרובות
לא ממש אכפת לנו איך וקטורים במרחבי הקוד שלנו נראים כי בדרך כלל לא צריך לדעת את זה כדי להשתמש
בקודים אז אם ההסבר הזה לא היה ברור זה באמת לא משהו לדאוג ממנו יותר מדי אבל זה בהחלט
טבעי לשאול איך וקטורים במרחבי קוד של קודי CSS נראים והתיאור הזה מספק תשובה לשאלה
הזו עכשיו נדון בקוד CSS ספציפי שנקרא קוד הטורוס שהוא דוגמה למשהו שנקרא
קוד קוונטי טופולוגי לתיקון שגיאות הקוד הזה התגלה על ידי Alexei Kitaev ב-
1997 למעשה קוד הטורוס הוא לא קוד בודד אלא משפחה של קודים אחד לכל מספר שלם חיובי
לפחות שניים לקודים האלה יש כמה תכונות מפתח התכונה הראשונה היא
שלכל מחוללי המייצבים יש משקל נמוך כפעולות פאולי ספציפית לכולם יהיה
משקל ארבע וזה טוב כי זה אומר שכל אחת ממדידות מחוללי המייצבים לא צריכה
לערב יותר מדי qubit לפעמים מדברים על קודי LDPC קוונטיים או קודים קוונטיים עם בדיקת זוגיות
בצפיפות נמוכה וזה מה שהמונח הזה אומר כאשר במקרה הזה נמוך זה ארבע אז קוד הטורוס הוא דוגמה לקוד
LDPC קוונטי לקוד הטורוס יש גם מה שנקרא לוקאליות גיאומטרית שאומרת שלא
רק שלמחוללי המייצבים יש משקל נמוך אלא שגם אפשר לסדר את ה-qubit במרחב כך ש
כל אחת ממדידות מחוללי המייצבים מערבת רק qubit שקרובים אחד לשני מה שהופך את המדידות האלה לקלות יותר למימוש
באופן עקרוני ולבסוף לקודים האלה יש מרחק גדול אז הם יכולים לסבול שיעור שגיאות יחסית גבוה
הנה איך הקודים האלה עובדים קודם כל יהי L מספר שלם
חיובי שהוא לפחות שניים וניקח סריג L כפול L עם מה שנקרא גבולות
מחזוריים לדוגמה הנה סריג L כפול L עבור L שווה 8 ושימו לב שהקווים
בצד ימין ולמטה הם קווים מקווקווים והרעיון כאן הוא שאנחנו רוצים לחשוב על הקו המקווקו בצד ימין כאותו קו
כמו הקו בצד שמאל ובאופן דומה הקו המקווקו למטה הוא אותו קו כמו הקו
למעלה אז אם באמת רצינו לממש תצורה כזו פיזית היינו צריכים שלושה
ממדים ספציפית אפשר ליצור גליל על ידי התאמת הצדדים השמאלי והימני ואז לכופף את
הגליל כך שהמעגלים בקצוות שפעם היו הקצוות העליון והתחתון של הסריג נפגשים או שאפשר
להתאים קודם את הקצוות העליון והתחתון ואז את הצדדים זה עובד בשני הכיוונים ולא משנה באיזה כיוון עושים את זה לצורך הדיון
הזה מה שמקבלים הוא טורוס או במילים אחרות סופגנייה למרות שלחשוב על זה כפנימית של צמיג
אולי תמונה טובה יותר שכדאי לזכור כי זה לא מוצק הסריג בעצם הפך רק לפני השטח של
טורוס ומכאן מגיע השם קוד הטורוס הדרך שבה אפשר לנוע על
טורוס כזה בהנחה שאפשר לנוע בין נקודות סמוכות על הסריג כנראה תהיה מוכרת לאנשים ששיחקו משחקי וידאו
ישנים שבהם אם זזים מעבר לקצה העליון של המסך מופיעים למטה וכך גם עבור הקצוות השמאלי והימני של
המסך וברוב המקרים ככה אתאר את הסריג הזה בניגוד לדבר ספציפית על
טורוס במרחב תלת-ממדי עכשיו נדמיין ש-qubit מוצבים
על הקשתות של הסריג כפי שמוצג כאן על המסך כאשר qubit מסומנים על ידי עיגולים כחולים
מלאים שימו לב אגב שה-qubit שמוצבים על הקווים המקווקווים אינם מלאים וזה בגלל שכבר ייצגנו את ה-qubit האלה
או על ידי אלה שלאורך הקצה העליון או הצד השמאלי בזכרון שהקווים למעלה ובצד שמאל הם בדיוק אותם קווים כמו אלה
שמסומנים על ידי הקווים המקווקווים למטה ומימין ואז אם סופרים את כל ה-qubit האלה מקבלים 2 כפול L בריבוע qubit ודרך
אחת לראות את זה היא לשים לב שמקבלים L בריבוע qubit על קשתות אופקיות ו-L בריבוע qubit על קשתות אנכיות
אז זה הפריסה של ה-qubit שלנו ולתאר את קוד הטורוס עצמו צריך רק לתאר את מחוללי
המייצבים ויש שני סוגים שלהם קודם כל יש לנו מחוללי מייצבים מסוג Z
ואלה מתאימים לאריחים או פלקטים בתרשים ושנית יש לנו מחוללי מייצבים
מסוג X ואלה מתאימים לקודקודים בתרשים אז לדוגמה הנה מחולל מייצב
אחד כלומר עושים טנזור של פעולת פאולי Z אחת עבור כל אחד מה-qubit שנוגעים באריח הזה יחד עם מטריצות יחידה
על כל ה-qubit האחרים וזה נותן לנו פעולת פאולי במשקל ארבע והנה דוגמה למחולל מייצב
מסוג X שבו יש מטריצות פאולי X שפועלות על ארבעת ה-qubit הצמודים לקודקוד הזה יחד עם
מטריצות יחידה על כל ה-qubit האחרים אז שוב זו פעולת פאולי במשקל ארבע חשוב ששני
הסוגים של מחוללי המייצבים כוללים את אלה שעוטפים סביב הגבולות המחזוריים והנה דוגמה למחולל מייצב מסוג X
שעושה את זה עכשיו כדי לקבל קוד מייצב תקף צריך שמחוללי
המייצבים יתחלפו מחוללי המייצבים מסוג Z כולם מתחלפים זה עם זה כי Z מתחלף עם עצמו ומטריצת היחידה
מתחלפת עם הכל וכך גם עבור מחוללי המייצבים מסוג X גם ברור שמחולל מייצב מסוג Z ומחולל
מייצב מסוג X מתחלפים כשהם פועלים באופן לא טריוויאלי על קבוצות נפרדות של qubit כמו שני המחוללים שמוצגים
כאן האפשרות הנותרת היא שמחולל מייצב מסוג Z ומחולל מייצב מסוג X חופפים
וכשזה קורה זה תמיד על שני qubit שבהם הם חופפים ולכן מחוללי המייצבים מתחלפים כי ZZ
ו-XX מתחלפים עכשיו זו לא קבוצה מינימלית של מחוללי מייצבים ספציפית אם מכפילים
את כל מחוללי המייצבים מסוג Z ביחד מקבלים את היחידה כי כל qubit מוכפל ב-Z פעמיים
פעם אחת עבור כל אחד מהאריחים שנוגע ב-qubit זה אומר שהכפלת כל מחוללי המייצבים מסוג Z
חוץ מאחד מהם נותנת לנו את האחרון אז הם לא בלתי תלויים אבל אם מסירים כל אחד מהם נקבל
קבוצה בלתי תלויה ואותו דבר נכון למחוללי המייצבים מסוג X אז אפשר להסיר אחד מכל סוג
ולא משנה אילו מסירים וזה משאיר L בריבוע פחות אחד מחוללי מייצבים מכל סוג להיות
ברורים לגבי זה וזה משהו שרמזתי עליו בשיעור הקודם אנחנו בעצם כן מתעניינים בכל מחוללי המייצבים האלה ובמובן
תפעולי קפדני לא נתעלם מאחד מכל סוג אבל לצורך ניתוח הקוד אפשר
לדמיין שמחולל מייצב אחד מכל סוג הוסר כדי שנקבל קבוצת מחוללים מינימלית בזכרון
שתמיד אפשר להסיק את התוצאות של המחוללים שהוסרו בהתייחס אליהם כנצפים מהתוצאות של כל מחוללי המייצבים
האחרים מאותו סוג אז מספר ה-qubit שהקוד הזה מקודד שווה למספר הכולל של
qubit שהוא 2 כפול L בריבוע פחות מספר מחוללי המייצבים הכולל בקבוצת מחוללים מינימלית שהוא 2 כפול L בריבוע מינוס
1 וזה אומר שאפשר לקודד 2 qubit לא טענתי אגב שמרחב הקוד הוא לא טריוויאלי אבל אכן
הוא לא טריוויאלי ואשאיר לכם לשכנע את עצמכם שאין דרך להכפיל מחוללי מייצבים ביחד בצורה שנותנת לנו
מינוס 1 כפול היחידה אז זה קוד הטורוס עצמו ובנקודה הזו אולי לא ברור
בכלל למה הקוד הזה אמור להיות טוב לתיקון שגיאות קוונטי נשאר לנו לנתח אותו ומה שנמצא הוא שהוא
בעצם קוד קוונטי מדהים לתיקון שגיאות כדי להבין איך קוד הטורוס מתפקד כקוד קוונטי לתיקון
שגיאות נתחיל בלהתבונן בשגיאות שונות ובתסמונות שהן מייצרות הדבר הראשון שצריך לשים לב אליו הוא
שקוד הטורוס הוא קוד CSS כי כל מחוללי המייצבים שלנו הם מחוללי מייצבים מסוג Z או X
ומה שזה אומר הוא ששגיאות X ושגיאות Z אפשר לזהות ואולי לתקן
בנפרד ולמעשה יש סימטריה פשוטה בין מחוללי המייצבים מסוג Z ו-X שמאפשרת לנו לנתח שגיאות X
ושגיאות Z בעצם באותה דרך אז אני אתמקד בשגיאות X שמזוהות אולי על ידי מחוללי מייצבים
מסוג Z ואפשר לתרגם הכל לשגיאות Z שמזוהות אולי על ידי מחוללי המייצבים מסוג X באמצעות בדיוק אותם
רעיונות הנה תרשים שמדגים את 2L בריבוע qubit שלנו על קשתות של סריג L
כפול L עם גבולות מחזוריים ואפשר לדמיין שזה פרוש על פני השטח של
טורוס כרגע כל ה-qubit הם כחולים שמציין שאלה qubit שלא הושפעו על ידי
שגיאות אז כדאי לדמיין שבנקודה הזו מצב ה-qubit האלה נמצא במרחב הקוד עבור הקוד
הזה כפי שהזכרתי המוקד שלנו יהיה על שגיאות X ועוד רגע נשתמש בעיגולים מג'נטה כדי לציין qubit ש
הושפעו על ידי שגיאות X שגיאות X מזוהות על ידי מחוללי מייצבים מסוג Z שמתאימים
לאריחים בתרשים אז מה שנעשה הוא לסמן אריחים לבנים כתוצאות מדידה של פלוס אחד או במילים אחרות
רכיבים בתסמונת שמתאימים למחולל הזה בעוד שאריחים אפורים יציינו תוצאות מדידה של מינוס אחד
אפשר לחשוב על תוצאה של פלוס אחד או במילים אחרות אריח לבן כמציין שמחולל
המייצב המתאים מרוצה הכל נראה בסדר עבור המחולל הזה בעוד שתוצאה של מינוס אחד או אריח אפור
מציינת שמחולל המייצב המתאים לא מרוצה כי ברור שהייתה שגיאה שגרמה לתוצאה
הזו אז כרגע כל מחוללי המייצבים שלנו מרוצים כי לא קרו שגיאות עכשיו אם חושבים
על מחולל מייצב מסוג Z כל מה שהוא עושה הוא למדוד את הזוגיות של 4 ה-qubit שנוגעים באריח
ביחס לבסיס הסטנדרטי אז תוצאה של פלוס אחד לא מציינת שלא קרו שגיאות X על ארבעת ה-qubit
האלה אלא מציינת שמספר זוגי של שגיאות X קרה בעוד שתוצאה של מינוס אחד מציינת
שמספר אי-זוגי של שגיאות X קרה אז עכשיו בואו נכניס שגיאת X ונראה מה
קורה שני מחוללי המייצבים מסוג Z שמתאימים לאריחים שנוגעים ב-qubit הזה עכשיו לא מרוצים כי
שגיאת ה-X הזו אנטי-מתחלפת עם שני המחוללים האלה או באופן שקול במונחי הבסיס הסטנדרטי אנחנו עכשיו ב
מצב ששתי קבוצות ארבעת ה-qubit המתאימות לשני האריחים הן בזוגיות אי-זוגית אז זו ההשפעה של שגיאת
X בודדת אז אם היינו מודדים את התסמונת הזו וידענו או הנחנו ששגיאת X אחת בלבד קרתה היינו
יכולים להסיק בקלות איזה qubit התהפך ופשוט להפוך אותו בחזרה עם gate מסוג X עכשיו בואו נראה מה קורה
כשמוסיפים שגיאות X נוספות ובפרט בואו נראה מה קורה כששגיאת X שנייה מתרחשת על qubit
אחר שנוגע באחד מהאריחים האפורים נגיד באריח האפור שלמעלה כך
האריח הזה עכשיו מרוצה כי שתי שגיאות X קרו על ה-qubit שנוגעים באריח הזה ושתיים זה זוגי אז
שתי שגיאות ה-X האלה ביחד מתחלפות עם מחולל המייצב עבור האריח הזה דרך אחרת לומר את זה היא
ששגיאת ה-X השנייה הזו הסיטה את כל מצבי הבסיס הסטנדרטי עבור ארבעת ה-qubit האלה מזוגיות אי-זוגית בחזרה לזוגיות
זוגית האריח משמאל לשגיאת ה-X החדשה מצד שני עכשיו לא מרוצה
אפשר להמשיך את התהליך של הוספת שגיאות X חדשות וכל עוד יוצרים שרשרת של שגיאות X סמוכות כאשר סמוכות אומר שה-qubit נוגעים באותו
אריח בעצם דוחפים את תוצאת המדידה של מינוס אחד הזו סביב ומה שמגלים הוא שתמיד יש
תוצאות מדידת תסמונת של מינוס אחד בנקודות הקצה של שרשראות שגיאות סמוכות אז תמיד אפשר לזהות שרשראות של
שגיאות X סמוכות כל עוד יש להן נקודות קצה ייתכנו אגב כמה שרשראות אבל נחזור
לאפשרות הזו מאוחר יותר אבל ייתכן שיש לנו שרשרת של שגיאות X סמוכות
שאין לה נקודות קצה כלומר שרשרת השגיאות שלנו יכולה ליצור לולאה סגורה אז בואו נוסיף עוד שגיאות כך
שהן יוצרות לולאה סגורה כזו למשל עכשיו יש לנו מספר זוגי של שגיאות X
על כל אריח אז כל מחולל מייצב עכשיו מרוצה ומה שמצאנו הוא שלולאות
סגורות של שגיאות X סמוכות לא מזוהות על ידי הקוד הזה כי מקבלים את תסמונת כל-הפלוסים במקרה
כזה אז זה עלול להיראות קצת מאכזב למעשה צריך רק ארבע שגיאות X סמוכות ליצור לולאה סגורה
ואנחנו מקווים למשהו טוב יותר מקוד עם מרחק 4 אבל כמה לולאות סגורות של
שגיאות X סמוכות הן בעצמן בתוך המייצב זכרו שיש לנו מחולל מייצב מסוג X עבור כל קודקוד
בסריג ואם מכפילים מחוללי מייצבים מסוג X סמוכים אפשר ליצור לולאות סגורות של פעולות X
כמו שיש לנו כאן עבור הלולאה הסגורה שבנינו לפני כמה רגעים אז כמה לולאות סגורות של שגיאות X
כמו זו שמוצגת כאן הן לא בעצם שגיאות בכלל כי הן בתוך המייצב אז הן לא עושות כלום למרחב הקוד אבל יש
כמה לולאות סגורות של שגיאות X שלא נמצאות במייצב ולכן הן מייצגות שגיאות לא טריוויאליות שלא
מזוהות על ידי הקוד ויש דרך די פשוטה לאפיין את הסוגים השונים של
לולאות לולאות שחוצות כל קו בסריג כלומר כל קו אנכי מלמעלה למטה וכל קו אופקי
משמאל לימין מספר זוגי של פעמים הן תמיד מכפלות של מחוללי מייצבים מסוג X זה כולל את הדוגמה
שמוצגת על המסך וגם לולאות שאולי הרבה יותר מסובכות כולל האפשרות שהן חוצות את הגבולות המחזוריים אבל
בכל זאת על ידי הכפלת הלולאות הסגורות של שגיאות X במחוללי מייצבים מסוג X אפשר בעצם לכווץ אותן
עד שנעלמות וזה בהחלט נכון אגב שאפשר לקבל לולאות כאלה רק על ידי הכפלת מחוללי מייצבים מסוג X כי כל מחולל מייצב
מסוג X שם מספר זוגי של פעולות X על כל קו אופקי ועל כל קו אנכי
הסוג האחר של לולאה סגורה שיכול להיות הוא כזה שחוצה לפחות קו אחד מספר אי-זוגי של פעמים כמו
זו שמוצגת כאן שחוצה כל קו אופקי פעם אחת בלבד והנה דוגמה נוספת שחוצה
כל קו אנכי פעם אחת בלבד אז אלה דוגמאות לשגיאות לא טריוויאליות שלא מזוהות על ידי הקוד אבל המפתח
כאן הוא שהדרך היחידה ליצור לולאה סגורה כזו היא ללכת סביב הטורוס או סביב החור שב
אמצע הטורוס או דרך החור או שזה יכול להיות שניהם זוהי תכונה טופולוגית
שנוגעת לטורוס הכל קשור לחורים בעצם וזו הסיבה שזה נקרא קוד קוונטי טופולוגי לתיקון
שגיאות במונחי הויזואליזציה הזו של סריג דו-ממדי עם גבולות מחזוריים שרשרת בקטגוריה הזו חייבת
ללכת סביב אחד או שני הגבולות המחזוריים בצורה שלא מאפשרת לכווץ את הלולאה לנקודה
על ידי הכפלתה במחוללי מייצבים מסוג X שרשרת כזו עלולה להיות מסובכת
יותר מזו שמוצגת כאן אבל זו הקצרה ביותר שלולאה כזו יכולה להיות כי היא חייבת איכשהו ללכת סביב
אחד או שני הגבולות המחזוריים ומה שזה מרמז הוא שהמשקל המינימלי של שגיאה לא טריוויאלית
שלא מזוהה הוא L כל לולאה סגורה עם פחות שגיאות מזה חייבת ליפול לקטגוריה הראשונה ולכן היא
במייצב ושרשראות שגיאות שלא יוצרות לולאות סגורות מזוהות על ידי הקוד וזהו זו הסיבה שהקוד הזה
עובד ומה שמקבלים הוא קוד מייצב [2L בריבוע, 2, L] משתמשים ב-2L בריבוע
qubit לקודד 2 qubit והקוד הוא בעל מרחק L עכשיו אגיד קצת על
תיקון שגיאות עם קוד הטורוס אם כי לא אכנס יותר מדי לפרטים אם מודדים את התסמונת
ורואים משהו שונה מתסמונת כל-הפלוסים כאשר אני מדבר כאן רק על מחוללי המייצבים מסוג Z
אז תוצאות המינוס אחד מציינות לנו את נקודות הקצה של שרשרת אחת או יותר של שגיאות X סמוכות ואפשר לנסות לתקן
את השגיאות האלה על ידי זיווג תוצאות המינוס אחד ויצירת שרשרת של תיקוני X ביניהן וכאשר
עושים את זה הגיוני לבחור מסלולים קצרים ביותר לתיקונים שלנו לדוגמה אם מודדים
תסמונת כמו זו שמוצגת כאן אז אפשר לבחור את המסלול הזה בין האריחים הלא-מרוצים ולהפעיל gate מסוג X
כתיקונים לאורך המסלול הזה כמובן ששרשרת השגיאות בפועל שגרמה לתסמונת יכלה להיות
שונה כמו זו שמוצגת כאן אבל זה בסדר כל עוד השגיאות והתיקונים ביחד
נופלים לתוך המייצב ייתכן גם שהתיקונים שלנו משלימים לולאה סביב
הטורוס וזה רע כי בכך גרמנו לשגיאה לוגית אז האסטרטגיה הזו של תיקון
לאורך מסלולים קצרים ביותר מתקנת שגיאות במשקל נמוך אבל היא לא בהכרח עובדת עבור שגיאות במשקל גבוה אבל כמובן אי אפשר
לצפות ליותר מזה מכל קוד קוונטי לתיקון שגיאות סביר יותר אולי בהתאם למודל הרעש הוא ש
נראה ערימה של מינוס אחדות בתסמונת ובמקרה הזה אפשר להשתמש באלגוריתמים קלאסיים יעילים כדי לעזור
לנו לזווג אותם ולמצוא שגיאה במשקל הנמוך ביותר שמייצגת את התסמונת כפי שהזכרתי בשיעור
הקודם זה לא בהכרח תמיד מתקן את ההסבר הסביר ביותר לתסמונת אבל זה עובד די טוב באופן כללי
וזה תמיד מצליח לתקן שגיאות עם משקל קטן ממש מחצי המרחק L וכדאי גם
לציין שיש אסטרטגיות אחרות שמתאימות יותר למודלי שגיאות שונים עברו יותר מ-25 שנה מאז ש
קוד הטורוס התגלה ובזמן הזה הייתה די הרבה עבודה על קודים קוונטיים לתיקון שגיאות כולל
קודים קוונטיים טופולוגיים אחרים לתיקון שגיאות שהושראו מקוד הטורוס וגם קודים שמבוססים על רעיונות
שונים אני בוודאי לא יכול לתת לכם רשימה מקיפה של כל בניות הקודים השונות שידועות אבל אגרד את פני השטח
קצת ואזכיר בקצרה כמה דוגמאות ידועות קודם כל כפי שמתברר זה לא
באמת הכרחי שלקוד הטורוס יהיו גבולות מחזוריים כלומר אפשר לחתוך רק חלק מקוד הטורוס
ולהניח אותו שטוח על משטח דו-ממדי במקום על טורוס ומה שמקבלים מזה נקרא קוד
שטח לדוגמה אם חותכים את הקצוות של סריג בדפוס שמוצג כאן עם מה שנקרא קצוות גסים
למעלה ולמטה וקצוות חלקים בצדדים ובהתאם כוללים מקרי קצה עבור מחוללי המייצבים
אז מקבלים קוד שיכול לקודד רק qubit אחד הפעם אבל הקוד בכל זאת יורש את המאפיינים
החשובים ביותר של קוד הטורוס בפרט שגיאות לא טריוויאליות שלא מזוהות עבור הקוד הזה חייבות
להתאים לשרשראות שגיאות שנמתחות מהקצה השמאלי לקצה הימני או מלמעלה למטה
תלוי אם הן שרשראות של שגיאות X או שגיאות Z בהתאמה אפשר גם לחתוך
את הקצוות באלכסון כדי לקבל מה שלפעמים נקרא קודי שטח מסובבים ולעשות את זה יכול לעזור להפוך
את הקודים ליותר חסכוניים מבחינת כמה qubit משתמשים לדוגמה אם לוקחים את קוד השטח
הזה וזורקים חלק מה-qubit ומשאירים ריבוע מוטה באלכסון מקבלים קוד שטח
אחר כל עוד מגדירים את מחוללי המייצבים בגבול בדרך הנכונה דיאגרמות כאלה
עוזרות להבהיר איך מחוללי המייצבים מוגדרים כאשר אריחים שחורים כולל המעוגלים בקצוות מציינים מחוללי מייצבים מסוג X
והלבנים מציינים מחוללי מייצבים מסוג Z אלה שבגבול אגב הם פשוט מחוללי מייצבים של שני qubit מסוג XX
או ZZ הפעם ולעיתים קרובות תראו את הדיאגרמות האלה מסובבות ב-
45 מעלות עוד סוג מעניין של קודים שגם נופל בקטגוריה הכללית של קודים טופולוגיים הוא קודי
צבע לא אסביר בדיוק איך הם עובדים אבל דרך אחת לחשוב עליהם היא שהם הכללות גיאומטריות
של קוד Steane של 7 qubit אז בואו ניקח את קוד Steane של שבעה qubit ונניח שאנחנו ממספרים את
ה-qubit לפי מוסכמת הסדר של קט כפי שמוצג כאן על המסך אז אפשר לשייך את שבעת
ה-qubit האלה לקודקודים של הגרף שמוצג כאן ומה שמגלים הוא שמחוללי המייצבים מתאימים
לאריחים או לפנים שנוצרים על ידי הקשתות של הגרף ולכל אריח יש תמיד מחולל מייצב
מסוג Z ומחולל מייצב מסוג X שפועלים באופן לא טריוויאלי בדיוק על ה-qubit שנמצאים בקודקודים של האריח
הזה זה נחמד כי בדיוק כמו בקוד הטורוס יש לנו לוקאליות גיאומטרית עבור הקוד הזה אז לא צריך
להזיז qubit על מרחקים ארוכים כדי למדוד מחוללי מייצבים והעובדה שמחוללי המייצבים מסוג Z ו-X תמיד פועלים באופן לא טריוויאלי על
בדיוק אותן קבוצות של qubit היא גם נחמדה מסיבות שקשורות לחישוב קוונטי עמיד לתקלות שעליו
אגיד יותר בשיעור הבא קודי צבע הם קודים קוונטיים לתיקון שגיאות שמכלילים את הדפוס
הבסיסי הזה שבו עושים בעצם את אותו דבר רק עם גרפים שונים לדוגמה הנה גרף עם
19 קודקודים שעובד זה נותן לנו קוד שמקודד qubit אחד לתוך 19 ומרחק הקוד הוא
חמש אלה נקראים קודי צבע אגב כי אחד התנאים הנדרשים על הגרף הוא שאפשר לצבוע את הפנים בשלושה צבעים כלומר
שאפשר לצבוע את הפנים בשלושה צבעים ולעולם לא יהיו שתי פנים באותו צבע שחולקות קשת
הצבעים לא באמת חשובים לקוד עצמו פשוט יש מחוללי מייצבים מסוג X ו-Z לכל פנים ללא קשר לצבע שלהן אבל הצבעים
כן מסתברים כחשובים לניתוח איך זה עובד אז אלה שתי משפחות קודים מאוד
ידועות אבל יש הרבה בניות אחרות שידועות כולל כאלה שמבוססות על רעיונות דומים למשפחות הקודים האלה וגם
על רעיונות שונים לחלוטין דוגמה ספציפית לקוד קוונטי לתיקון שגיאות שהתגלה לאחרונה
על ידי כמה מהעמיתים שלי ב-IBM ידוע בשם קוד הגרוס שנקרא כך כי גרוס הוא תריסר
תריסריות או 144 ספציפית הקוד הזה מקודד 12 qubit לתוך 144 qubit ומרחק הקוד
הוא 12 לא אסביר איך הקוד הזה עובד בפירוט הוא דומה לקוד הטורוס רק שכל אחד ממחוללי
המייצבים מערב עכשיו שני qubit נוספים שנמצאים קצת יותר רחוק אין לו שיכון מישורי
כמו לקוד שטח אבל יש לו מה שנקרא שיכון דו-שכבתי כלומר שצריך שתי שכבות של qubit במקום
אחת הוא שייך למשפחת קודים שנקראת קודי אופניים דו-שכבתיים ומה שמיוחד במיוחד בהם הוא
שהם הרבה יותר יעילים מקוד הטורוס או מקוד שטח במובן שהרבה יותר qubit אפשר לקודד ובו זמנית הם
סובלים בערך את אותו שיעור שגיאות עבור קוד הגרוס נדרשים עוד 144 qubit למדידת
התסמונת אז המספר הכולל של qubit הנדרשים הוא 288 מה שהופך אותו למועמד מבטיח מאוד לטכנולוגיה
של היום ובכך מסתיים השיעור הזה שעסק בבניות של קודים קוונטיים לתיקון שגיאות כולל קודי CSS קוד הטורוס והצצה
לבניות קודים קוונטיים אחרות כולל קודי שטח וקודי צבע אני מקווה שתצטרפו אליי ל
שיעור האחרון והמסכם של הסדרה על חישוב קוונטי עמיד לתקלות שמתמודד עם האתגר של ביצוע
חישובים על מצבים קוונטיים מקודדים באמצעות פעולות ורכיבי חישוב שהם עצמם נוטים ל
שגיאות להתראות עד אז